i'm outside the cbs broadcast center
right now because the moment we've all
been waiting for
is here for over a week now our show has
been
on the road in the drew van driving
across the country
from california to right here in new
york and many of you spotted the van
and sent us your pictures i've met some
great people along the way
and who have reached out to us while
seeing the van
we've met drew gooders i met a wonderful
woman
who inspired me we added businesses to
our small business gift guide
and they went on a barrymore tour and
found a snake named drew in albuquerque
new mexico guess what
it's karen and noah
we made it oh my gosh finally you guys
are here
we are we are so good to see you in
person
hello thank you for letting us put our
logo
on your van which is just so well done
thank you you really decked it out and
created a lifestyle
really it's you know it's meant to be an
experience
it's really not meant to be a thing it's
meant to facilitate
seeing the world and that's what this is
about and also for the record you don't
need a van to see the world just go
thank you for being the representatives
of showing people what's possible to do
with their life
oh you're so welcome we think that
spontaneity equals joy
you know our lives are so regimented and
when you can break out of that even if
it's for a long weekend
and you have the ability to just stop
and be in the moment
and go wherever your fancy takes you i
mean it's this freedom that we just
don't have
i mean especially in this covid year
right
and yet people i think have been more
inventive about road tripping
what do you say to people that are too
scared
to let go of the permanence and comfort
of their position or job
and hop in a van and go see the world
you know i think that's actually changed
a lot in the last year um we
living in the bay area were very close
to silicon valley um there's there's
actually a new
term that's that's emerged called
digital nomads people who actually want
to work from their vehicle work from
their van
work from their car airbnb around the
world you know and and
work and and i think it's a new thing
it's a new emerging thing that i think
people is going to catch on
a lot of companies are not going to go
back to work yeah and so i think this is
kind of here to stay
and so um in our little way we've
contributed to that
there's so many other ways that that you
can do that and and that
have emerged that facilitate that well i
think when people see your van
and see how livable it is and stylish
and beautiful
it's going to be a huge source of
inspiration and i think it's confidence
building what you guys do is like
go for it life is short live your dreams
and you know make the most of the time
we have here on our planet
so i am so excited about this now i
heard there's
actually a montage we get to watch of um
the sticker idea my 90s zine girl that
wants to like throw drew's news stickers
i am dying i can't even help it or hold
back i just want to see it
it's amazing we got to go to the best
places and do that oh my gosh
can i tell you where we did our favorite
yes we did cadillac ranch in texas
amazing art installation in the middle
of the desert we did the twin
arrows trading post in arizona which is
like these
huge skyscraper size arrows that look
like they've been shot into the desert
floor
incredible on route 66 we did
the oh the baghdad cafe remember the
movie
yes amazing it's still there and then we
did
um sun studios in memphis tennessee
where all those guys
started elvis johnny cash oh my gosh
there are drew's new stickers right
outside
elvis's studio oh my gosh
i can't believe it can i ask um
definitely a highlight for me watching
you guys was the drew snake
i don't know why i just have a lot of
affinity for this albino snake named
drew
um a rattler
was there any geographical location or
landmark or
little cafe anything that really stuck
out for you
as gosh i wouldn't have thought that
that would be such a highlight but it
turned out to be
you know you haven't lived until you've
watched the sunset
in sedona um i i
it's i i'm at a lack of words for
describing that rock
we were we were right there we were
directly below what was the bell
um bell rock we climbed sort of a third
of the way up bell rock and watched the
sun set
um we sat on top of the van which is a
cool little van life trick you can
actually sit up on top of the van
we watched the stars for an hour and a
half on the side of the road we saw this
really weird
we thought it was a ufo at the time
turns out it was a bunch of satellites
that launched last week that were
spreading themselves
so they say yeah it is sedona that isn't
yeah
far from was it area 54
yeah not that far and we just watched
the stars
and and later and you know honestly one
of the best things about this
we love love love our children they're
amazing it's been 14 years
since karen and i got to go away just
the two of us for more than a you know a
night here there
um thank you for that i am
so happy for you i have to say we found
it surprisingly easy to let go
i thought there was going to be more
guilt i thought there was going to be
more i need to call home now
you know we were able to relax i think
we are going to go home
100 recharged i this was the greatest
gift
in these times thank you so much makes
me so happy oh
what a good thing to come out of this
well we have to go to a quick commercial
break but when we come back noah and
karen
are revealing their road tripping tips
to make your next vacation
so delightful and if there's anyone i
want to hear it from it's two people
that feel as fulfilled as you do